[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir les trous noirs c'est vrai sont
peut-être les dont 10 de l'espace temps
les pirates de l'univers où les
corsaires du cosmos il invite
effectivement à tout réinventer mais je
crois surtout à cheminer avec une
nouvelle rationalité qu'ils ne
renieraient rien de la raison de sa
rigueur naturellement mais qui
imposerait peut-être une
déterritorialisation quelque chose qui
ressemblait à de l'errance ou un peu de
plus rivaux cité l'idée pourtant est
assez simple si je jette un objet vers
le haut il monte il redescend sauf si je
le jette suffisamment fort parce
qu'alors il va échapper au champ
gravitationnel de la terre et s'envoler
pour toujours dans l'espace c'est ce
qu'on nomme la vitesse de libération
mais si la terre était contractée par
une main de géants devenait donc plus
dense
il serait plus difficile de s'échapper
de son champ gravitationnel et par
conséquent la vitesse de libération
augmenteraient si je poursuis le
processus vient nécessairement un
instant où la vitesse de libération
devient plus grande que la vitesse de la
lumière
nous venons de créer le concept de trou
noir tel qu'il est connu depuis le
xviiie siècle
si la vitesse de libération et plus
grandes que la lumière rien pas même la
lumière ne peut s'échapper du champ
gravitationnel de l'astre considérait
alors l'idée est simple presque évidente
trivial mais les trous noirs existe-t-il
vraiment peut-on les voir non peut pas
aller voir parce qu'ils sont trop petit
parce qu'ils sont trop sombres mais
peut-être faut-il se départir du primat
que l'on confère usuellement à la vision
avez-vous déjà vu
l'amour le ressentiment la haine les
champs magnétiques
pourtant il existe exister
étymologiquement c'est le contraire
d'insister ça veut dire avoir des
conséquences mesurable sur son
environnement et sa en effet on observe
on voit les orbitent des étoiles autour
du trou noir central de la galaxie on
voit qu'il ya une masse qui est immense
très petit et très sombre
sept exactement la définition d'un trou
noir
les trous noirs sont nombreux il y en a
vraisemblablement des centaines de
millions dans notre galaxie et ne sont
pas dangereux
ce ne sont pas comme on le dit parfois
des ogres qui dévore tout sur leur
passage
si le soleil devenait un trou noir
l'orbité de la terre demeurerait
exactement la même parce que la
gravitation est démocratique
les trous noirs ne sont pas non plus
comme on les représente dans certains
livres de vulgarisation des entonnoirs
ce sont des sphères presque parfaite des
sphères caractérisée par une surface
qu'on nomme horizons et qui est en
quelque sorte immatériel on ne se heurte
pas sur un trou noir
vous qui entrez ici perdez toute
espérance
c'est ce qu'écrivait dante dans sa
comédie pour décrire les enfers et c'est
effectivement un peu ce que sont les
trous noirs pour donc ré enchanter
pourrait-on dire c'est monde lugubre et
ténébreux il faut recourir à une théorie
magnifique qu'on appelle la relativité
la relativité restreinte
elle nous montre d'abord qu'il existe
une vitesse absolue indépassable elle
nous montre surtout qu'il est possible
de contracter l'espace et de dilater le
temps du simple fait que je bouge ma
main par rapport à la vôtre
ma montre se désynchronise légèrement de
la vôtre ce qui veut dire littéralement
que les voyages dans le futur sont
possibles que nous pourrions tous
devenir plus vieux que nos propres
parents
la relativité restreinte nous montre
aussi e égal mc2 que l'on peut
transformer une propriété l'énergie en
existence la masse
mais au-delà de ces étrangetés fait la
très grande et très fascinant théorie
d'einstein la relativité générale qui va
vraiment éclairé d'un nouveau jour les
trous noirs la relativité générale elle
ne montre que l'espace se distord et se
distend eu égard à la présence des corps
elle nous montre pourrait-on dire que la
matière façonne l'espace et qu'on retour
l'espace infléchi dicte à la matière
ce que sont les trajectoires possibles
l'espace c'est à dire la gravitation
devient dynamique
c'est dans ce cadre qu on peut
comprendre l'expansion de l'univers
pour les trous noirs je dirais que le
premier changement induit par la
relativité et visuel un trou noir c'est
pas simplement un disque sombre qui va
obstruer le ciel d'arrière-plan un trou
noir en réalité c'est quelque chose qui
va engendrer un chapelet d'image
pourrait-on dire spectrale et sépulcrale
du ciel étoilé
parce que la lumière peut suivre des
trajectoires complexes dans cet espace
déformé par le trou noir
ça nous invite aussi à comprendre qu'une
même expérience peut être appréhendée de
façon différente une pierre par exemple
qui tombe sur un trou noir sera vu par
l'observateur locales comme entrant dans
le trou noir à la vitesse de la lumière
mais un autre observateur lointain verra
la pièce se figer à la surface du trou
noir
ce sont des visions apparemment
antagonistes et pourtant parfaitement
cohérente d'un même monde dans une
acception relativiste c'est aussi la
relativité qui nous permettent de
comprendre que les trous noirs sont là
encore littéralement et sans métaphore
des machines à voyager dans le temps
si je m'approche suffisamment de
l'horizon d'un trou noir sont rentrés à
l'intérieur et donc on pouvant
m'extraire de sa présence
j'aurais littéralement vécu peut être
dix minutes
domont référentiel propres pendant que
se seront écoulés des millions ou des
milliards d'années dans le reste de
l'univers et les deux durées sont tout à
fait exact de leur point de vue de leur
acception et de leurs mesures
respectives
alors la relativité ça permet aussi
d'aller plus loin et d'imaginer des
voyages dangereux par exemple à
l'intérieur des trous noirs dans un trou
noir
on peut y pénétrer parce que
rappelez-vous l'horizon est immatériel
je ne ressens rien quand je pénètre dans
la stroke lui mais les choses deviennent
un peu complexe je ne peux plus
m'arrêter
c'est nécessairement dynamique je les
coulées m'effondrer en quelque sorte la
singularité centrale cette espèce de
déchirure de l'espace-temps qui
d'ailleurs stricto sensu n'est pas un
point situé quelque part mais constitue
plutôt un achèvement de l'écoulement du
temps dans un trou noir
la lumière émise vers l'extérieur va en
réalité vers l'intérieur parce que dans
un trou noir
l'espace se change en temps et le temps
se change en espace de la même manière
que dans notre monde
le temps s'écoule inexorablement nous
vieillissons dans un trou noir
c'est l'espace qui s'écoule et on ne
peut pas contrer cet écoulement
un astronaute téméraires ou imprudents
qui entrerait dans un trou noir verrait
comme dernière image un cerceau un
anneau de lumière infiniment brillant
séparant deux hémisphères
extraordinairement sombre c'est une fin
je trouve qui ne manque pas d'un certain
panache
alors on peut aller plus loin encore et
considérer les trous noirs tous les
trous noirs en rotation les appelle les
trous noirs de care ces trous noirs qui
sont réelles parce qu'en réalité les
étoiles tournent donc les trous noirs
qu'elle engendre tourne également
présente des propriétés remarquables
l'espace-temps est entraînée par la
rotation un trou noir à l'intérieur de
l'horizon on voit apparaître non plus un
univers mais une multiplicité et même
une infinité d'univers de gravité
répulsive et attractive on ne sait pas
très bien aujourd'hui s'il s'agit d'un
simple artefacts artifices mathématiques
c'est tout à fait possible c'est même
probable mais peut-être s'agit-il en
réalité des premières traces des
prémices de ce qu'on nomme un multi vas
1 cette multiplicité de monde traverse
toute l'histoire de la pensée ou la
trousse les grecs anciens avec un maxime
andré démocrite on la trouve à la
renaissance avec de cues rabelais bruno
on la trouve à l'âge classique avec
leibniz au xviiie siècle avec fontenelle
et en philosophie contemporaine avec
goodman et lewis ce qui est remarquable
c'est que c'est possible pluralité
d'univers fait aujourd'hui via les trous
noirs effraction pourrait-on dire dans
le cadre très rigoureux de la physique
théorique
le grand mathématicien rogers penrose a
compris également que les trous noirs
pourraient constituer une source
d'énergie presque infinie est
extraordinairement écologique il serait
d'ailleurs une machine de recyclage
absolument parfaite en extrayant
l'énergie de rotation ah oui on peut pas
récupérer ce qu'il ya dans le trou noir
puisque rien ne peut sortir mais on peut
en revanche juillet de l'énergie
associée au mouvement du trou noir alors
hélas un c'est une boutade de physiciens
théoriciens parce que il ne vous a pas
échappé que dans le monde réel nous ne
vivons pas à proximité d'un trou noir en
rotation
donc notre salut si ça lui il y a ne
viendra pas du miracle technologique ou
scientifique mais plutôt du sursaut
éthique puisque vous savez que nous
sommes en train de nous suicider en
quelques décennies nous saccages ont des
millions d'années d'évolution subtil est
fragile et la catastrophe sans précédent
dans l'histoire de l'humanité et
vraisemblablement sans précédent dans
l'histoire de la terre que nous
engendrons et que nous subissons emmène
dans son sillage quelques millions
d'espèces quelques milliards de
milliards de vivant non humains par
ailleurs terriblement réifier par notre
hargne froide et c'est la raison pour
laquelle je crois que nous ne pouvons
pas ne plus en faire notre préoccupation
première et c'est la raison pour
laquelle même dans un exposé sur les
trous noirs
je pense qu'il est indispensable de le
rappeler mais on peut aller
mais on peut aller encore plus loin
grâce à la physique théorique et on peut
s'intéresser à la conjonction des trous
noirs avec la physique quantique
vous savez cet étrange théorique décrit
le monde l infiniment petit monde qu'il
y a de l'aléatoire qu'il ya du jeu
continue et qui nous montre aussi que le
vide n'est jamais vraiment vide
en fait la physique quantique peuple
pourrait-on dire le vide de petites
paires de particules et donkey
particules sporadiques comme ça qu'ils
apparaissent et qui disparaissent qui
scène il tout aussitôt sauf s'il ya un
trou noir le champ gravitationnel du
trou noir par effets de marée va pouvoir
casser les pères de particules est l'une
des particules sera émise vers l'infini
autrement dit l'observateur distante qui
scrute le trou noir verra en réalité un
rayonnement d'évaporation émaner du trou
noir
c'est en contradiction patente avec tout
ce que je vous explique depuis dix
minutes puisque de façon définitive war
rien ne peut sortir d'un trou noir et on
est en train au contraire de dire que
les trous noirs s'évapore oui c'est un
peu le problème c'est que la science
contrairement à ce qu'on dit parfois ce
ne sont pas des réponses trivial à des
questions complexes
c'est toujours une invitation à la
subtilité les gros trous noirs ne
s'évapore pas et tout ce qu'on a vu est
correct mais les petits trous noirs
formé juste après le big bang pour être
en effet être en réalité de véritables
bombes qui explosent et qui rayonne
toute leur énergie vers l'extérieur
d'une façon qui à ce jour demeure
mystérieuse parce que les trous noirs
semblent amnésique l'énergie rayonner ne
conserve pas la mémoire de ceux qui a
formé le trou noir
mais ça c'est interdit vous savez en
grèce ancienne vérité se disait aletheia
aletheia avant tout ça veut dire mi mai
6 ça veut dire se souvenir
hélas les trous noirs violent l'un des
théorèmes les plus fondamentaux de la
physique qui est la conservation de
l'information
à ce jour personne n'a d'explication
convaincante à ce paradoxe fondamental
de l'information des trous noirs
alors aujourd'hui les regards se tourna
vers l'observation
parce que depuis quelques années vous
savez peut-être que nous disposons d'un
nouveau sens
en quelque sorte après le doral
vue l'ouïe le toucher et cetera grâce à
nos instruments
nous sommes maintenant en mesure de
percevoir les petites vibrations de
l'espace on appelle ça les ondes
gravitationnelles
ce ne sont pas comme la lumière des
ondes qui se déplace dans l'espace ce
sont des ondes d'espacé l'espace
lui-même qui se met à vibrer et grâce à
ces ondes de gravité
nous avons scruté la coalescence c'est à
dire la fusion de deux trous noirs et
ceci nous a permis de mesurer de façon
claire que les trous noirs sont biens
immatériels
ils sont pourrait-on dire des boules de
géométrie le défi pour les prochaines
années et ça sera ma conclusion c'est de
tenter avec les trous noirs d'aller plus
loin vers ce qu'on appelle la
gravitation quantique
parce qu'aujourd'hui les physiciens sont
un peu schizophrène il ya d'une part la
relativité la théorie de l'univers et
d'autre part la physique quantique la
théorie des particules
mais le problème c'est que ces deux
théories ne sont pas compatibles l'une
avec l'autre
alors on dit parfois qu'il faut les
rendre compatibles pour unifier la
science ça j'y crois pas trop
moi j'aime bien pensée une science
diversifié polychrome trois pays forment
un monde un peu anarchique mais le
problème c'est la cohérence pour décrire
les trous noirs
je dois utiliser simultanément les deux
théories et lorsqu'elles sont
mutuellement exclusifs ce n'est pas
possible il faut aller plus loin
peut-être avec la théorie des cordes qui
invite à penser les trous noirs comme
une sorte de gaz de structures filiforme
vibrante et de membranes ce qui permet
d'expliquer leur complexité
peut-être avec la gravité quantique à
boucles qui invite à penser les trous
noirs comme des objets hors bons trous
noirs devenant troublant le trouble en
aidant le symétrique d'un trou noir un
objet dont on peut extraire mais dans
lequel on ne peut pas rentrer pourquoi
on les voit pas d'ailleurs c'est
troublant peut-être simplement parce que
le rebond est très rapide dans son
référentiel propre quelques
microsecondes
mais grâce à la théorie de la relativité
vu par l'astronome extérieur il peut
être beaucoup plus long que l'âge de
l'univers
alors vous le voyez les questions sont
nombreuses
je crois que il ya beaucoup de
découvertes encore à mener avec les
trous noirs
il me semble qu'il faut continuer de les
scruter avec des yeux d'enfant à la fois
naïf rigoureux et enchanté en gardant en
tête peut-être ces quelques mots de pier
paolo pasolini qui nous rappelait que
pour apprendre il faut toujours d'abord
savoir aimer merci
[Applaudissements]